hmm that's a new one hey everyone i'm
abbey sharpe welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at winnie haye's wedding a day and as
always you can pause the screen or look
at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always please feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey and of course if you are new
here don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and ring that little bell so
that you never miss out on an episode
but first let me tell you what my
sponsor case to five so as a mom with
two kids who are low-key obsessed with
screens my phone has taken a real
beating over time it isn't pretty but
the phone works still and i would love
to prolong its life as long as possible
with a good case so i recently stocked
up on these super cute case defy phone
cases my only regret is not getting one
sooner to have better saved my screen
but the case defied chi-tek 2.0
technology in the ultra impact case
offers powerful drop protection of up to
9.8 feet
aka it is definitely toddler proof and i
also love the wireless charging and 5g
options plus the fact that they use an
antimicrobial coating called defensify
that kills 99 of bacteria again toddler
proof and case defies new impact and
ultra impact cases are made of 65
recycled and plant-based materials not
to mention the prints are all so cute
they have really fun images and graphics
in literally every color plus you can
also opt for one of their customizable
options with your favorite font design
and copy so if you want to protect your
phone and style yourself go to
casetify.com slash abby sharp to get 15
off of your new iphone 13 case all right
super quick winnie hayes is a mom and
food content creator who often documents
her family friendly and kids meals but
today we're going to be taking a look at
her personal wedding day and also close
off on some thoughts on her approach to
feeding her kids let's take a look for
breakfast i made this vanilla protein
oatmeal with banana blueberries toasted
coconut flakes peanut butter and a
little bit of honey okay this is amazing
looking so she said protein oats so i
assume we've got protein powder in there
and we've obviously got lots of fiber in
the oats and berries plus healthy fats
in the nut butters and coconut this is
textbook hunger crushing combo here
and almost too pretty to eat almost in
my protein shake there's blueberries
greek yogurt banana almond milk and
protein powder okay so this is pretty
similar to the oatmeal bowl but without
the spoon so we're getting protein from
the protein powder and yogurt plus carbs
and fiber from the fruit and depending
on the type of yogurt we may also have
some fat now i do get asked a lot about
low versus no versus full fat dairy and
ultimately it's a personal choice but i
do always recommend full if you like it
i think it's more delicious that's
number one and more satiating thanks to
the fat and contrary to what you might
think the research actually suggests
that high fat dairy is associated with
lower risk of weight gain and chronic
disease now this is a quickie short
video so i don't know if these meals are
also being shared with her kids and also
in another video which i'm going to
comment on in a minute i did see that
she made her kids a smoothie without
protein powder but just as a teachable
moment for those of you watching i
generally do recommend avoiding protein
powder for kids it's rarely actually
necessary nutritionally since kids
protein needs are actually quite low
less than 20 grams for kids four to nine
years old for example which honestly
isn't that hard to get even for the days
they like live on carbs but supplements
like protein powders are generally quite
poorly regulated and not all are well
tested for impurities heavy metals
and other neurotoxins so these are
things that our body as adults may be
able to process in small amounts but it
could be a significant load for a young
child and that's not to say that all
protein powders have dangerous heavy
metals lurking in them but again this
isn't well regulated by the food system
so i do prefer to stick to protein
sources that are regulated as foods when
it comes to kids so things like greek
yogurt powdered peanut butter tofu hemp
hearts etc so sometimes if i want to
save time i'll just make a kid's
smoothie and then add a little protein
powder to my glass at the end for lunch
i made this spicy tuna poke bowl with
sushi rice avocado cucumber sea greens
and seaweed okay so i think poke bowls
are inherently quite well balanced like
we're getting some healthy fats and
fiber from the avocado carbs from the
sushi rice as well as some protein and
healthy fats from the tuna now the
seaweed is also a great concentrated
source of iodine and the amino acid
tyrosine which both together work to
support healthy thyroid function but if
the kiddos are getting in on this it is
ideal to limit higher mercury fish like
tuna and also be very careful about
serving kids raw fish a lightly poached
salmon would be a really great
family-friendly choice to get in those
heart-healthy omega-3s without the risk
for dinner i had this soup and salad
thing going on
oh minestrone is one of my all-time
favorites
[Music]
i think we've got some plant-based
protein in the white beans carbs in the
noodles and loads of fiber from the
veggies and salad and i also love that
the vitamin c inherent in the
tomato-based soup will help to enhance
the absorption of the plant-based iron
and i'm just gonna assume that we have
some fat in the salad dressing to just
like tie this all together now it would
probably be a pretty light meal for me
so she wanted to serve like a little
crusty bread on the side it would help
to balance everything out nicely but
honestly it just looks like a really
delicious meal and for something sweet i
had this chocolate greek yogurt bar and
that's it i hope you guys have enjoyed
this video i will see you next time okay
finally for dessert winnie is enjoying a
chocolate greek yogurt bar which
provides about 5 grams of protein and
about 100 calories it's a light bedtime
snack but also one of my personal
favorites with a little science to
support its use so dairy products like
greek yogurt are rich in the amino acid
tryptophan vitamin d if fortified and
melatonin all of which help to support
quality sleep and pairing carbs with
protein
actually allows the tryptophan to more
easily enter the brain and enhance
serotonin production so this is a great
built-in snack with some of those
benefits but if we wanted to get a more
substantial dose because again this is a
very small little bar we could actually
make our own popsicles by blending some
greek yogurt with some nut butter maybe
some bananas and some other fresh fruits
and then freezing them in little molds
very much kid and also good sleep
approved now before we get into the
analysis i want to just quickly comment
on some of the strategies that i've seen
from winnie when it comes to feeding her
family that i absolutely can get on
board with let's take a look at an
example of our kiddos breakfast two cups
of milk and one cup of rolled oats
now remove from heat and add a little
bit of vanilla i'm going to add here
since the kids can put whatever they
want on their oatmeal and we are ready
for our breakfast
okay so while it might seem like a lot
of extra work here to lay out all these
little toppings this diy oatmeal parfait
is beautifully aligned with what we call
the division of responsibility of
feeding so as i discuss in my video on
raising intuitive eaters right here our
job as parents is to determine what and
when it's time to eat but our kids get
to choose from those options and also
how much they're going to eat or if they
eat it all now laying out a variety of
nutritious oatmeal toppings all of which
you as the parent feel good about
serving not only is super visually
appealing and also very fun but it also
increases the likelihood that something
will be consumed since the kids feel in
control they are the masters of their
breakfast are you taking over the house
yes you are not to mention serving food
family style is a great way to reduce
waste and also the power struggles that
often occur at the table so here we have
some leftover fruits and i'm just going
to add them into this freezer friendly
ziploc bag and put it in a freezer look
at that like no waste at all and i
actually do the same thing in my house
with like half eaten apples or bananas
or pears i just think like my kids
always want an apple or a banana and
they take like two bites of it before it
gets abandoned on a shelf somewhere so i
just chop it up and i freeze it for
smoothies the next day i just know that
i have this one last carrot in the
fridge that i wanted to use so i'm going
to use a wavy knife and cut them into
fry okay if you have a picky eater you
will be amazed the difference a new fun
shape can make my youngest o
uh has really always been a more
selective eater since he started solids
than my eldest e we've gone through many
veggie strikes around here and one of
the only things that gets us back on
track are little fun veggie cutters to
make different shapes so if you're
struggling with picky eating in your
house especially around things like
veggies my tip is to remove all the
pressure to eat them and instead
encourage vegetable play so for example
stack up the zucchini coins make a face
with the peas have a little sword fight
with a carrot stick we need to reduce
the anxiety before we can even have a
chance of our kids wanting to have a
taste and little fun food cutters or
silly utensils can be a great way to
play i ended up adding about a quarter
cup of pesto and now we're just going to
add our pasta and just stir it all up
together okay so this is another great
tip for introducing a new novel food we
call it fading so if you know that mac
and cheese is a sure-fire safe food that
your kids will almost always accept and
like adding in a teeny tiny bit of a new
sauce or a new spice or a little
vegetable and then increasing that
amount over time until maybe we have
like straight up pesto pasta is a great
way to expand a picky eaters palette and
then that was pretty much it my kids
really love this one yes the carrot
fries some slices of orange and a little
bit of ketchup this made quite a bit of
pesto mac and cheese my kids actually
took it to school and they had it for
after school lunch this meal looks
incredible so we've really got
everything that i would look for in a
balanced kids meal carbs in the pasta
protein the chicken fat in the pesto
cheese sauce plus some kind of fruit or
veggie and that brings me to another
really important feeding tip don't shy
away from dips even the really sugary
ones like ketchup dips are a great safe
bridge food to help encourage children
to try new foods on their plate even if
they just lick the dip off the food
they're learning to like the fact that
they put the food in their mouth is
often a huge win for families with picky
eaters so think about kids nutrition as
a long game i am personally way less
concerned with the amount of sugar in
the ketchup if in the end having ketchup
means they have a more varied and
therefore nutritious palette and diet
okay but let's bring it back to winnie
for a second and talk about her personal
way of eating so on this particular day
i'm estimating a completely normal
average amount of calories and fiber and
a healthy split of macros it was a short
video so we didn't get a whole lot of
commentary and maybe what night in day
videos should all be like that like show
me the food inspiration not the moral
baggage that seems to accompany every
eating decision you make
i would love to see more content that
just plainly says hey
this is what i like or this is what i
can afford or this is what i had in the
fridge or what was available to me and
just leave it at that and yeah winnie is
an amazing home chef and mom with
recipes that are inherently well
balanced and relatively simple and
accessible i also think she's got some
incredible kid meal ideas for families
who maybe feel like they're stuck making
the same four meals on rotation and
while she's not a pediatric dietitian
she actually utilizes a lot of the
feeding strategies that the experts in
this field recommend i also really
appreciate that despite kids meals kind
of being a large part of her brand i
don't really see her posting her kids a
lot online and you guys know i've talked
about my own reasons for keeping my
family out of my feeds but it almost
feels rare to see that nowadays in the
influencer world but i personally will
be coming back to winnie's platforms in
the future the next time that we are in
a meal rut like maybe tonight i don't
know what we're making for dinner so
winnie hit me up and on that note that
is all that i have for you guys today
and if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on who or what you'd like to see
me or few next subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]